they remain commercially successful so
doing the right thing doesn't have to be
bad business
parents carers of course we're there to
look after and love our children but how
much do parents including myself see
their children they're at school 190
days a year 10 hours a day they're in
the high street playing with their
friends and the whole point of this
strategy is that we pre you know we want
parents to be the best parents in the
world but when they're not in the home
you know of course we want the high
streets to be safer we don't want them
you know marketed to with junk food on
their ipads and their phones and their
games we don't want our olympic events
and biggest sporting events owned by
sugar and are they listening
well i hope they're listening but this
is a game in there's a game out here's
the real world you know i i did the
whole thing where's me eating mess gone
the eating mess was just a bit of fun
you know i didn't want people to turn up
today and be aggressive or violent or do
what they were doing in washington or in
paris you know i wanted to be british
about it and have a laugh but the eating
mess is profoundly symbolic of a very
privileged part of society you know the
kids and families most affected by this
are in the poorest communities if you
look at the map of of of of the poorest
it's also the map where kovid had the
highest mortality it's not right now is
the time to act i i've seen what
hopeless looks like when i when i did
the school dinners campaign 15 years ago
which is where we had more legal
standards for dog food and we had none
for kids food 190 days of the year guess
who was pepping up then guess who gave
me grief then the only minister
boris johnson and he was he was shut up
in 24 hours because he was an
unimportant minister at the time like
this man hasn't had a precedent of
caring about people whether they're
vulnerable or not poor or not so you
know i was hoping that his near with
death
and his recent fatherhood
might inspire him to feel
feel
this differently this is not like a cute
campaign it ain't jazz hands this this
is fundamental and it's for all your
people listen it's not about one thing
here and one thing they like to be
annoying like it's as profound as the
smoking ban it saves lives
it's about making young people do better
live longer and be more productive is he
protesting against me
obesity policy no okay we have we are
very very uh
we understand the vital importance
of of tackling obesity it costs the nhs
huge huge sums of money uh if people
feel uh healthier happier um their
quality of life is much much better if
if they lose weight speaking entirely
personally now
there are lots of things you've got to
you've got to focus on uh including uh
diet eating less or eating less is the
most important thing
but there are some things at the moment
where we think they make very little
difference to obesity and they can
affect people's weekly outgoings
people's budgets and at this particular
time if people can save on their on
their food bills uh with with some
offers then i think we've just got to be
flexible whilst continuing to tackle
obesity